[Music]
there's a drive that I have to stay
sober because I know that my life
depends on it
demi lovato opens up to ET about
maintaining her sobriety the 24 year old
singer was honored for her work in the
mental health community at the UCLA open
mind gala and now you just celebrated a
big milestone five years sobriety what
is it that keeps you on this this path
and wanting to use your platform to
speak out it's something that if I would
have continued down that road it would
have been I don't know if I'd be here
today so it's something that's very
important to me and then I've been able
to share my story with other people and
I've had fans that come up to me and
tell me you know because you got sober I
got sober and it's just been a really
beautiful thing that you've really been
vulnerable in your music in the past
give me the truth what is the
inspiration for this new album like what
do you see this time around what I'm
channeling is things that I'm going
through today which are different you
know they everyone goes through ups and
downs and I'm getting to write about
that I'm in a new chapter in my life and
so whenever I'm writing about that I
keep that in mind
[Music]